[Music]
she's your basic average girl and she's
here to save the world now on the big
screens but Disney's been hiding some
secrets about this movie stay tuned to
find out which cameo will make you
completely change your mind about the
reboots don't forget to hit that
notification Val to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's get to some hot deets on the Kim
Possible live action movie for someone
who's supposedly a mad genius I'm not
seeing much of the genius people wanted
a different shego unless you're a
Twitter fan you probably missed the fact
that people who aren't really happy with
the casting will dive deeper into this
later and check out as many details as
possible because there's a lot to get
through but let's start with one of the
most talked-about characters
shego who is one of those characters
many people totally fell in love with so
getting the right actress to represent
her is quite important in the
live-action movie she go is played by a
new actress called Taylor Ortega and we
can't wait to see what she'll bring to
the table but many Twitter fans pointed
out that the ex member of fifth harmony
would make an absolutely perfect shego
people fan casted the movie before the
real cast was actually announced and by
the looks of it Lauren her eggie made
the cut of course at least in the fans
eyes the dark haired brown eyed latina
definitely has this shego look but
unfortunately it looks like Lauren is
dedicating all her time to launching her
highly anticipated music career people
have also pointed out that the singer
Demi Lovato would make an amazing she go
along with the actress sofia boutella
while twitter definitely did this job at
fan casting for the live action movie
the she go role ultimately went to
Taylor Ortega and to be fair she can
definitely pull off the she go look to
here's how Twitter reacted to the cast
needless to say many people had high
expectations for the Kim Possible
live-action movie after all and has to
go head-to-head with the iconic cartoon
that left a mark on many of our
childhoods so it's no wonder some people
didn't really approve of the live-action
outfit reveal for Kim Twitter fans Jo
but the outfit looks like the last
resort party city costume and that Kim's
sassiness is totally gone
others have joked that Kim Possible just
became Kim I'll see what I can do
Kim's outfit and the original cartoon
was pretty awesome but could this work
as a sufficient replacement many fans
have come to defend Disney's choice for
Kim and pointed out that the actress is
in fact a child we're just so used to
seeing older people play teenage roles
we forget that Kim was actually a
teenager so it would make total sense
that the character is played by a kid
even though she might not look Kim's
exact age people also pointed out that
this is why Hollywood should stop
casting 25 year olds as teenagers as it
totally skews our outlook on what
teenagers are supposed to look like
either way the Kim Possible live-action
movie is definitely sparking debates
both directors were on a reality show
apart from their impressive resume we
usually get a lot of news about movie
directors and if we do they're never
good but this time the Kim Possible
movie has probably one of the most
interesting director news we've ever
heard Zack Lepofsky and Adam B Stein
were in a reality show together yep they
appeared on the 2007 reality series
called on the lot the series featured 16
inspiring filmmakers who competed to
become the next big Hollywood director
the winner got a development deal with
the one and only DreamWorks which is a
pretty big deal for new filmmakers both
Zack and Adam already have an impressive
resume and they even worked together on
a sci-fi thriller called freaks so Kim
Possible should be a walk in the park
for these two the actual reality series
on the lot featured celebrities such as
Adrienne Acosta and Carrie Fisher the
show had mixed reviews and some fans
equated it with American Idol if your
place singing with showcasing your
creative film work it looks like this
directing duo actually met on the show
and by the looks of their continued
collaboration they know how to cook up
some real film magic can a reality TV
duo pull this off a nod to That's So
Raven we love a good 90s throwback but
what's even better is seen a live action
movie giving a tribute to another iconic
show one of the biggest surprises it is
Isaac Ryan Brown who plays wade all
this isn't a direct tribute it's
exciting to hear that Isaac's actually
starring in Ravens home for replays
Ravens son wow that's a reboot on its
own it's exciting to hear that some of
our fave 9 tea shows will be coming full
circle we love a good reference and
we're really excited to see Isaac
playing Wade what do you think is this
an intentional nod to that so Raven or
just a bizarre coincidence keep an eye
out for Isaac in the movie considering
Kim Possible had a ton of references and
fantastic one-liners it's safe to assume
the live-action movie will deliver
something similar who knows maybe this
isn't the only nod to That's So Raven
that will exist either way it's just one
of those things you'd never even know
unless you really research the actors
that are in the movie this casts really
turning out to be quite interesting
isn't its first live-action of its kind
Disney has been surprising us with
live-action remakes for years and the
response is usually pretty well received
sure there are initial doubts sometimes
the classic just doesn't need to be
modernised you know but they definitely
proved us wrong over the years and
always managed to deliver a new
perspective on the old classic but did
you know that this is their very first
take on remaking a series we've seen
movies such as Cinderella Beauty and the
Beast and even the latest Christopher
Robin but did you notice that Disney
never bothered to tackle any TV series
oh well until now not only is Kim
Possible highly anticipated it will also
set a bar for any future Disney TV
series remakes that might arrive and in
case you're wondering 2019 and 2020 will
be amazing for Disney live-action
remakes along with plenty of other
movies we're also getting the Lion King
in 2019 and the Mulan reboot in 2020
reboots are often a hit and miss but
based on Disney's track record
Kim Possible will do just fine despite
the doubts from the audience
Sadie's Stan Lee is a brand-new actress
speaking of doubts when actresses
sparking way more debate than any other
this is Sadie Stanley's very first
acting role and she already landed a
role
and one of the most anticipated movies
of 2018 can you believe it her only
previous role was for a minor part and
her character didn't even have a name
but Sadie is very dedicated to talking
to the Kim Possible fanbase and giving
them updates if you follow her on
Instagram you'll get to see a ton of
behind the scenes from the movie not
only is Sadie totally gorgeous but this
16 year old is also the same age as Kim
would be in season 3 of the original
series what better person to play a kid
than an actual kid despite being a
brand-new actress Sadie displayed plenty
of professionalism she already looks
like a seasoned pro and we have a
feeling we'll be seeing more of this
teenage star imagine going from being
casted in your first role as a giggling
girl on game shakers in 2018 to getting
one of the biggest roles ever it's a
true dream come true and an inspiration
to anyone that thinks they can't make it
calls to browses response this movie
actually got so much backlash when it
comes to casting other stars had to step
up to shut it down the backlash not the
movie Cole Sprouse who you might know
from Riverdale actually had a few words
for the people that disliked the cast
and he said exactly what others have
previously pointed out his tweet said
that there are a lot of adults directing
hate towards a couple of kids because
their childhood cartoon doesn't look the
same anymore he then pointed out that
the people need to grow up and realize
they're talking about kids who are
likely happy to ever gotten the job he
also mentioned that these kids might
also hear them and read the terrible
comments in a way the backlash is a form
of cyber bullying and we can only hope
that the kids have a strong support to
not let this faze them and affect their
performance others have also pointed out
that just because Sadie is brunettes and
not a redhead it doesn't mean she's not
perfect for the role we're pretty sure
the cast will still deliver the best
live-action version of Kim Possible
Christina Milian's believe it or not
Disney still hasn't confirmed whether
Christina Milian will play any part in
creating a soundtrack for the live
action movie in case you forgot she's
the one that created the iconic call me
beat me theme song
it turns out a lot of people actually
have no idea she's the voice behind the
song since she's still around and making
music why not invite her back
well so far Disney hasn't confirmed
anything christina actually talked about
her surreal experience hearing people
have the song she's saying as her
ringtone she also said that she might
get a remix of the song one day and sing
it at her concerts and Disney was the
one that actually called and beeped
Christina and asked if she could sing
the theme song she recorded it a week
after she first met with the producers
which is amazing she also said that she
might have to tune a few bits of the
theme song to make it more relevant and
poppy with the current trends honestly
what a better way to do it then on the
actual live-action movie Disney we're
still waiting for that announcements
LGBT characters if you browse Twitter
long enough you'll notice that Kim
Possible has a special place in the
heart of the LGBT community for many it
was one of the first signs of their
sexuality and for others it taught them
how to be truly themselves well believe
it or not but impossible actually has a
gay character on the show and no it's
not Kim and she isn't in love with she
go put those fanfictions away I am DB
lists gay dad as one of the characters
and it's played by Christopher Logan
sure it might not seem relevant enough
but considering Disney is still quite
silent on including LGBTQ characters and
basically anything we're here for this
there's also a gay dad number two and
he's played by Kenneth / BAE there isn't
much information out there and since
none of the two characters actually have
a name we're assuming they're just minor
supporting roles but nevertheless will
actually see gay dads on our screens if
you know about Disney's history with
LGBT characters you'll know this is a
huge deal
since the LGBT community definitely
deserves more representation in the
Disney World we can't wait to see even
more characters with bigger roles in the
future a special cameo the big moment
has arrived no the actual movie isn't
here yet but we are giving you the
biggest detail that's remained quite
hidden if we told you there was at least
one can possible cat
member you'll be glad to see would you
believe it no seriously even if you're
not a fan of the current cast this one
person will definitely change your mind
actually there are two because professor
Dementor is played by the same person
and although the Kim Possible role was
given to Sadie Stanley the real Kim
Possible will also be making an
appearance yep this movie will come full
circle because christy carlson romano
will be having a cameo it's not yet
clear what it will be of course but we
have a feeling it will definitely make
the og Kim Possible fans scream we told
you this movie really won't be as bad as
you think
with that said what do you think about
the Kim Possible live-action movie love
it hate it how do you feel about the
cast comes share your thoughts below and
chat with other members of our community
and cue the sharks and that's it for our
video thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]